hello welcome to another exciting
episode of the movieclips instant
trailer review show I'm Jimmy I'm Ryan
and today we're reviewing the
long-awaited sequel of dumb and dumber
dumb and dumber 2 yeah it's altea we're
jumping right in it it has been two
decades and they acknowledged that very
early on um apparently in the world of
the film the time has passed and all
they've done is this yep this question
kind of yeah the thing is i was talking
to Jimmy about this a little bit um
they're so old-looking and the fact that
they're in the same costumes and stuff
yeah it now Jeff Daniels though I have
to say he doesn't he doesn't look like
he's aged as much yes maybe it's cuz I
don't also has like the scraggly hair he
kind of looks like a little guy yeah but
Jim Carrey with the like straight like
bang nothing yeah you'll really see it
later on like if it wasn't a parent
already um they're they're gonna hello I
got such a one she back that up we're
gonna have to cut this one wait what
happened sorry I thought we did tell her
the catheter
oh cool once you roll me inside we'll
get the girls take your category we
don't need nurses for that don't you so
I do want to acknowledge this is the
raunchiest green van trailer I've ever
seen in my life yeah um I'm really
really visit there's a catheter joke a
butthole joke and then at the end
there's something beyond what I could
even yeah well get to that one but yet I
mean like here you can already see like
it's just that I think it's the way it's
the way the hair works it's like it
looks like an SNL skit of him like doing
dumb and dumber again yeah but the SNL
skit is like that he's too old to do
dumb endeavor but you can see these two
of the worm farm they're still doing a
thing yeah it's the thing is is that
they obviously slip back into these
characters very easily and there are so
many moments in the trailer that are
like classic Dumb and Dumber oh yeah
absolutely um so I you know I are you a
huge fan of yours I'm a huge fan of the
original they came out just like right
in this region here is just like a force
of great grow back to the original we
should notice the absence of lauren
holly was everyone um hi we have the
Binaca like all the discs offices but
there's Ron wriggle from from The Daily
Show
do you think I have a serious question
for you Jimmy do you think that dumb and
dumber humor plays 20 years later I
think it does like that movie was huge
try to I this I would like to point out
this does take place in Rhode Island um
just yourself Providence RR mmhmm yeah
lovely City big fan of Rhode Island I
heard the fart the Farrelly Brothers Oh
are from are the from oh yeah if you
look at all their movies are really all
been there room in central a really take
place in providence lot of them that's
true or the new england area like fever
a fever pitch yep um yeah the one
helping well it took place in boxes
that's a lovely film I think the
Farrelly Brothers have a big heart and
they they really one big heart between
them no I heard an interview with them
they were really it was funny because
there was when they were doing Three
Stooges who and i think was peter
farrelly was talking about just how even
though the movie is really ridiculous
and zany and and some of their movies
have been sort of full spectrum ones
like very home and hardy and the other
ones are really just out of control they
really really tries to imbue a sense of
warmth and and family and love I think
this that comes across I mean look at
the movie like stuck on you the riches
are endearing yeah they're enduring yeah
I mean they have something about mary
which is probably their most iran tree
and then like stuck on you is a really
sweet movie I think that's somehow they
got that same with this this movie
there's the dogs are ugly this is my
cousin movie though could be one of the
more watching movies with me I mean
based on the trailer is great this is
this Asik Dumb and Dumber react
I wonder if like little like kids will
respond to this the way kids responded
to in 1994 I've always loved Jeff
Daniels period Harry just the hairy bear
you smile huh it's just so great Jeff
Daniels is I I think one of the most
underrated actors on the planet he's
really incredible he just has that so
let's just talk this is horrific Lee
disgusting yeah and I can't believe that
either this is like they're literally on
the apartment they're just doing old
lady vagina jokes yeah at this point I
was like okay yeah this is really wrong
code and then further like that's
unbelievable I think so like so somebody
taking their children to see whatever
this runs with so let's say how to train
your dragon 2 there's no way the kids
will know there's no way this will run
before that movie oh absolutely not
today I'm guessing do you think they're
going for an R rating no it is it's it's
is it gonna confirm that it's an r-rated
the first one was not first one was not
what I think it's I think it's a great
decision on the part of the studio and
just everybody because look the audience
I grew up they did they grew up exactly
the audience is aged and I think in
order to get the draw that film needs to
be successful they need to have
something a little bit extra yeah when
this came out on video my parents Mary
trepidatious Lee rented it to let me
watch it and thought it was hilarious
but now mom and dad I can go see this on
my own absolutely with my own ID but
yeah nice sa I'm I'm totally totally in
for this one
the the first movies just hold such a
special place in my heart I quote it
very it was a cultural phenomenon yeah
it really is it's it's just so good yeah
so good so a trailer that is I will
always watch I will always watch it when
I like some scrolling through the
channels appreciate yes USA open at
worst how much it probably is on yeah um
so a trailer that shows the funniness
that this movie is going for and and is
beyond anything I've ever seen in a
trailer in terms of raunchy until next
time I'm Ryan and I'm Jimmy thank you
for watching
t